now here is anthony
d as the reds looking for a double
header sweep
next pitch is swung on and missed and uh
that didn't go very well
wrecking ball way out of the strike zone
that he swung at here's the 2-2 pitch
and there's strike three fastball locked
up
key brian hayes two punch-outs for
anthony diesclefani in the first
one on two out here's colin moran
frazier at first
and they'll both be on the move hit to
the left field corner
frazier just now touching third he's
gonna be waved home
relay from suarez safe rbi double for
colin moran
and the pirates open with the lead and
they will face
mitch keller here in game two of the
doubleheader
keller is only 24 years old he pitched
last year in the big leagues had 11
starts
3-2 pitch runner goes and it's a swing
and a miss for the strikeout
and a strike him out throw him out
double header
as kevin newman the second baseman took
that one hop throw from
jacob stallings and applies the tag of
akiyama
and now vado with a fly ball to left and
frazier is there to make the catch we
played one
it's the pirates one red's number
reynolds hitless in two
trips in game one struck out his last
two times reynolds must feel like the
world's against him there's a ground
ball right side
off the glove of diving first baseman
joey votto
and there's a hit for reynolds we'll do
the 3-2 again
see you later third strikeout for diesel
funny just swung
underneath the high fastball strike
three-call
back-to-back punch outs for disclaifani
well the reds could really use a good
outing by diese cafani
and followed by another and another good
outing and it puts runners at first and
second
for eric gonzalez swing and a miss
punched out five pirates through the
first two innings that brings brian
goodwin up with one on and one out
six for 31 since coming over to the reds
another player steering the nationally
yet to hit his stride
two weeks left in the season here's a
drive to left field did goodwin
get enough he did how about that stride
he'll stride around the bases his second
home run
in a red's uniform just a nice easy
swing by brian goodwin right there
and just like that it's 2-1 cincinnati
two on
second inning here's the pitch ground
ball right side and right at the second
baseman newman on to first for the final
out and after two innings
since he two pittsburgh one and
castillanos leads off
against mitch keller here's keller's
pitch
swing and a miss at a high fastball good
start second time he's gotten casteanos
tonight well he looks like a different
header
joey votto one ball no strike count
here's a drive to right field kiss it
goodbye
way out of here second home run of the
day bravado he had one in game one
is ninth overall here in game two
three to one rep going to the fourth
inning it'll be josh bell
bell had the base hit in the first josh
bell hits a high fly ball to deep center
field
and clear the deck cannonball coming for
bell
josh bell hits his seventh home run of
the season
and the buck's within one it's three to
two and now the payoff pitch
got him sixth strikeout for d stefani
pirates bad in the fourth inning these
govany's pitch to newman bounced to the
left side
suarez gloves throws on the run in time
newman's out pirates are done they get
one on a solo homer from josh bell
javis wall now bat from the right side
against this lefty
you threw the fastball by him he swung
and missed he's out and that's that
the 2-2 called third strike
and on to the fifth in this seventh
inning game we go
a two-out single brings up key brian
hayes
there's a drive toward left field keep
ryan hayes
deep and clear the deck a cannonball for
key
get the grocery cart ready key brian
hayes hits his second big league home
run and gives the pirates a 4-3 lead in
the fifth inning
and the bases are loaded for gregory
polanco
here we go popped up high into the air
left side of the infield suarez has it
and romano two-run home run by
kei brian hayes has made it a 4-3 pirate
lead
so the reds now with runners at first
and second base
two down in the inning or mike mustakas
when stock is over for two
into right center field this one hit
very well
three run home run oh
baby the reds retake the lead six
four reds mustaches proves large
oh my goodness the reds with a golden
opportunity to add on here
ace is loaded no one down top of the
order
and he walks in a run does hartley hit
batter three straight walks in a 7-4
reds ground ball past the shortstop
this will play one and the reds have an
8-4 lead
boy for a minute there i didn't think
gonzalez is going to be able to get out
of the way of that ball
[Applause]
that hit vital gets away here comes the
runner to the plate casalli
scores 9-4 rebs pirates down to their
final out
in the air and this will do it
outstanding day at the office for the
cincinnati reds on david bell's birthday
they gift him with a doubleheader sweep
of the pirates